i'm trying to be a more adventurous
eater but
it's hard
i was watching this uh food show
and this uh guy was eating food
hey guys pete here this will be my mayor
of east town episode 5 breakdown
as has become the standard a ton of
things happen across the cast of
characters
as we near the end some of these things
are overshadowed by the big events but
everything still feels like it might
turn out to be important so i tried my
best to include everything
and do have to give a quick spoiler
warning before we get started
for anyone who might have wandered in
here without watching the episode first
with that out of the way let's get into
it
there are a lot of new developments but
a lot of incomplete
information to go along with them how
did ryan know something was going on
with his dad
why did dylan reach out to jess about
aaron's journal
and why is she misleading the police for
him if deacon mark was with aaron on the
night she
died what else does he know and there's
also a ton of revelation so i'll start
at the beginning
the first casualty of the episode was
betty carroll
she had a heart attack and crashed her
car into a telephone pole
the new cop who had an issue with the
sight of blood in the first episode
arrives on the scene to identify the
body
the crash causes the power to go out and
at laurie's place she walks by her son
ryan's room and here's her husband john
telling him to keep a secret
john tells him that everything will be
all right but this is just between them
no one else can know about it at mare's
place her ex-husband frank comes over
and when he talks to siobhan
we learn that things aren't going well
between him and his fiancee faye for the
first time
but he says they'll get through it they
have a father-daughter moment when he
asks her how she's doing
and she tells them that she met someone
we'll come back to frank at the end
but the siobhan story in this episode
seems pretty straightforward
her new older girlfriend who isn't part
of the east town where everyone knows
everyone else dynamic is continuing to
try to get her to think about leaving
the place behind
while mare's looking for drew's turtle
she sees her daughter's documentary on
her laptop and watches a clip of kevin
she shot on his birthday when he was
still a kid
this hits her pretty hard and we'll see
that she keeps thinking about it
throughout
the episode we also see her continue to
go to therapy throughout
we get a lot of information in the first
visit she talks about how kevin was a
normal kid
and how his issues progressed the
therapists ask her if there's a family
history of mental illness
from that we learned that her dad was
depressed that she's had periods of
depression herself
and we knew that her father had died
when she was 13
but here we learned that he actually
shot himself this is a pretty
big revelation not only did kevin die
from suicide but her father did
as well she asks if mental illness is
something you pass on through the
generations
and this works to reinforce why she's so
terrified
for drew later at home we see the rosses
come over
everyone seems to be in pretty good
spirits at first
they're talking aaron's dad kenny asked
lori and john about adopting dj
you can see where he's coming from with
that his relationship with dylan might
be awkward going forward
and mare doesn't really comment on the
idea of adoption
but does ask them if they thought kenny
hit her
it feels like a strange shift but this
is where things start to get
interesting we had seen lori looking at
drew and we know there's something
building under the surface
there jon says that kenny didn't hit her
but laurie follows up right after him
qualifying
saying that they all knew he wasn't
treating her right
we also learned that aaron's mother died
of leukemia
but didn't tell anyone about it until
the end and so john compares aaron to
her
being tough but then he says that they
took care of her because kenny wasn't a
good dad
then lori drops the bomb when she says
that aaron lived with billy for a while
mara lights up and when she asked him
about it he plays it off like it was a
long time ago and he doesn't really
remember the details
the reasoning was that her mother had
just died kenny was drinking a lot and
they didn't want her around that
situation
again lori adds to the conversation
pointing out that it was longer than a
few weeks but it was more like a couple
of months that she stayed with him
from there he goes straight to nervous
he looks at his
watch tells everyone he has to leave and
it looks like he's making an excuse to
everyone there
he had just opened a fresh beer and we
see mara look at that
and it's pretty clear that she thinks
something's up
the next day laurie gets called to pick
ryan up from school
after he knocks the crap out of this kid
in the lunchroom after seeing him bully
his sister
when they get in the car she asked him
what his dad was telling him to keep a
secret about
she asked is he doing it again and ryan
runs out of the car
she finds him crying on a picnic table
and when she asks him again
and adds is it the same woman as before
he nods his head yes later in the
episode we'll see lori crying in her
room
then we see john is packed up and he's
ready to leave
he may be going to a hotel for a few
days he may be leaving for good we don't
really find out we don't hear anything
that they say to each other
we only see him say goodbye to ryan and
try to console him try to tell him it'll
be all right
and we just see that ryan ignores him as
he goes out the door
i mean the implication is that jon is
having an affair he's had them in the
past
but it is short on details and i will
come back and talk about john a little
bit more towards the end
elsewhere in town as missy's experience
in opiate withdrawal katie's taking care
of her
when asked she says she's been there for
about a year and that there was another
girl there named hillary who took care
of her when she was experiencing the
same thing
when asked what happened to her katie
explains that she got pregnant and that
he didn't like it and there was some
discussion about what the kidnapper was
up to
i thought that it was pretty clear that
he was using them for sex
and i think everything we see in this
sequence backs that
up because we see him come in and he
ties them up so that they'll be quiet
when he has people over for poker night
also we saw deacon market beat up at the
pizza shop
he comes home and father dan tries to
console him tries to find out what's
going
on he wants to call the police but mark
won't let him
and there we get another big revelation
that he was with aaron the night that
she was killed
she had called asked him to pick her up
at sharps woods
she got another message and that led to
him driving her to brandywine park
that's the park where her fingertip was
found and what colin and mayor assumed
to be the
crime scene where they found the bullet
lodged in the tree
he said on the way there he was trying
to talk her into going home but she was
hysterical
and then he just says that she stormed
off when then asked him why he didn't
tell the police he said he was scared
because of his
past allegation and he had her bike in
the car so he threw it in the river
which you can kinda see why he might do
that however
no one's gonna believe him now and with
the story about what happened at the
other parish getting out
it's likely that even if he is innocent
it's not going to be easy for him to
prove that
i think the big twist in this episode
was everything dealing with dylan
first we see him with brianna he says
that his parents are also thinking of
adopting dj
that they talk to child protective
services he asked about her assault case
we get the idea that they haven't been
together much we didn't see her at the
hospital at all
she tries to be supportive and he's kind
of keeping her at arm's length
and then she drops a bomb saying that
she woke up on the night that aaron was
killed and he wasn't in bed
he tries to make excuses and she shoots
them all down
she looked all around the house and she
knew he wasn't there
he tells her to leave and he doesn't let
up until she does
later we see jess come out of her
apartment building she gets into a car
with him and his friend
and when asked she tells dylan she
pointed mare to an old hiding place for
the journals
she mentions that mayor called back
after she found the necklace
and basically it comes out that she was
misleading the police because dylan told
her to
now we don't know why and we don't know
how long this has been going on
it's still not a hundred percent clear
if she went to see lori and tell her
about
frank because she actually believed that
or if that's something that dylan told
her to do
as well either way they break into
aaron's house they go into her room they
find the journals in their hiding place
dylan also finds money that she was
saving for dj
surgery it doesn't look like a lot but
he does pocket that and even though they
seem to have had a pact that they
wouldn't read the journals
jess still is there's a page we see on
screen where aaron mentions it being
hard you know being a single mother
and mentions deacon mark trying to help
her find solace in god more or less
later we see them burn the diaries in a
fireplace
jess is still reading through them and
then we see her pull a photograph out of
one of them and put it in her pocket
there's something going on with these
kids that's for sure dylan got up and he
left on the night that aaron died
and at this point we don't know why
they're working together or what they're
trying to accomplish
there is a ton of mare and colin in this
episode
it's fun to watch and a good setup but
the way it plays out is that it's all
just there to set up a dramatic
ending they go out on a date and we find
out that mayor only agreed to that
because she wanted to pick his brain
about the case
he gets frustrated and tells her about
it and she gets pretty cold and ends up
leaving
there is mention of this girl hillary's
case the one that katie was talking
about being there when she arrived but
in the end it turns out they didn't even
need this to find the kidnapper
before we get to that we see marilyn in
bed with drew
she's thinking about the incident with
kevin in the bathroom
we see her continue to go to therapy
where it looks like
with each time they show her she's more
open to the treatment
on her way home at night she sees the
same person she thought was a peeping
tom from episode 1.
this time she chases after him to find
out that he's a 77 year old
dementia patient but she doesn't find
that out until after she throws him down
his stairs
she gets chewed out about this and the
chief definitely looks pissed but he
doesn't do anything he just tells her to
go home
this doesn't slow her down from working
the case just as the bad date doesn't
keep her away from
calling and i guess it was right around
the time that his mom told him to just
be careful out there that i really
started to worry about whether he was
going to make it through this episode
alive
through their conversation with the girl
that got away from the kidnapper they
get a partial plate
before they get the report on those they
have a chance for her to explain that
her life's screwed up and she's sorry
but she's not able to be what he wants
that gives him a chance to confess that
he didn't really solve the cold case
it was really a private investigator
that the victim's family hired
colin initially ignored him but when he
did get around to going to talk to him
he found out that he was sick he was in
hospice he was dying
and he got a hold of the file and
realized that he did find something and
colin used that to make it look like he
solved the case
to make him feel better about it she
confesses that she planted the drugs on
carrie
and he gets his moment to give her a
kiss saying
how do you know what i want and we see
that there's a moment where this is
starting to work for her
there's still a chance at a romance
between these two
it isn't meant to be though they arrive
at mr potts place
he's got some loud judas priests playing
and when the camera pulls out as they
walk into his house
we see the benny sign on the other side
of the building
he goes into the bar area to turn down
the music and colin notices that pack of
winston
sitting there mayor goes for her gun and
realizes she doesn't have it
and colin unbuttons his in the holster
katie and missy hear the voices
downstairs and realize
he wasn't expecting these visitors since
he didn't chain them up
they use the opportunity to start
banging on a pipe
and mare and colin notice this right
away things get super tense as they
continue
and just as zabel's going for his gun
pot shoots him in the head
and i mean it's a direct head shot we
see the blood spatter on the wall coming
out of the back of his head
mare gets her injury as she's running
away she gets shot in the hand but she
makes it out of the room
she tries to hide but notices the camera
and realizes he might know where she is
through a hole in the floor we see
colin's body on the ground downstairs
with the gun next to it
there's a super intense slow motion
chase
she discovers the girls but she can't
open their room
she's hiding he's shooting through the
walls and she grabs a piece of metal and
hits him over the head twice that buys
her enough time to run downstairs
there she's able to get to colin's gun
and is able to shoot pots
several times he looks pretty dead and
we see the squad cars pull up
as she was able to text them in the
process
and the police come in and she's sitting
against the door thinking of that video
of kevin
and it cuts to black and the episode
ends there
so rest in peace colin and mr potts
they both look pretty dead after last
week's recap
and the follow-up video on the trailer
breakdown and theories
i had a lot of comments starting to
wonder if colin might be
a suspect where things are left i think
that's probably not the case
i think we found out his dirty little
secret and we didn't learn much about mr
potts but it does seem like he was
operating on his own
and that his intention was just to use
these girls as sex slaves
at the end we do get closure for the
katy bailey case
we should see her reunited with dawn and
kenzie mayor continuing to work the case
was the difference in seeing this thing
through and there was a price
detective colin zabal looks like he paid
it with his life
overall this was one of the most
gripping endings of an episode in the
series
they did a solid job in setting up the
pieces to make things
incredibly intense in the face-off
inside benny's tavern
even after picking through the trailer
for clues i really wasn't sure if they
were gonna be where the girls were being
held when it all went down
as it played out losing colin was like
having the wind knocked out of you
the fact that he fumbled his way through
their date and still couldn't let go of
his ideas about mayor
it all worked really well if nothing
else it's going to have an impact on
mayor going forward and she's already
got a lot of
other regrets and pain that is all
competing for her attention
you feel for mayor and i thought most of
this was handled well
but from my perspective there's still
this yeah that's awful
but energy in her story i like mare and
most of her backstory
is super compelling i mean not only did
her father commit suicide when she was a
teen
but her son followed in his footsteps of
course i like a flawed character but the
power dynamic between her and
carrie is so skewed that it's still hard
to accept how things played out
plus she doesn't seem to have any
remorse about doing what she did
and everyone that knows about it seems
willing to write it off as yeah that's
just mare
but the story isn't told yet so we'll
see where they go
with the kidnapper out of the way the
path is cleared to get to the bottom of
aaron's story
who is dj's father who killed her and
essentially what do these things say
about the town of easttown
in an episode where we got some answers
things also took
some unexpected turns and as i mentioned
at the beginning our understanding of
the developments is incomplete
if i hadn't watched the trailer the
dylan ingesting would have been a
complete surprise
and i was shocked when brianna said that
he left the house on the night aaron
died
the ross family and the deacon mark
reveals were a little more telegraphed
but it still isn't clear how things are
gonna play out the pace is still full
speed ahead
the answer to new mysteries ratio isn't
getting too lopsided which is nice
and there are still some funny moments
to lighten things up from time to time
most of those belong to jean smart and
this episode was no exception
i really loved her face as she was
grabbing food as mr carroll was coming
clean about their affair
she also had a very human moment when
she was with carrie
telling her that she was helping her for
purely selfish reasons
because she's afraid carrie's gonna get
full custody and cut them
out of drew's life and she can't bear to
lose another one
the spotlight being on the rosses also
makes me wonder about faye and frank
having problems
sure she would have been mad at him
because of what happened with mare
coming over to their house
but they're having ongoing problems
hints that there may have been
other suspicions or something else going
on before that happened
lori caught a lot of my attention i know
she had the underlying tension with jon
going on but it seemed like she was
really kind of
nudging mare to maybe pay attention to
her husband
an old weird cousin billy on top of that
they're obvious suspects that were
flying under the radar because they were
the somewhat normal hometown types
they seem mostly like good guys but lori
is in a unique position to know things
about them that nobody else does
i'll get into all of that more in the
follow-up video the trailer this week
isn't quite as juicy so we'll be able to
get through that pretty quick and focus
on
end game theories that'll come out in a
few days
for now there's a lot to think about rip
rip
to betty carroll and colin zabel let me
know in the comments what you think
about the episode what you think about
that
ending and where you think things are
going from here
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon